[Music]
just a minute ago
this oil helped make a delicious meal
possible but now it's just some nasty
goop what should we do with it well the
easiest thing would be to pour it down
the drain that makes it seem like it's
gone but it's not really gone instead
it's collecting bits of food and other
random stuff producing monstrous greasy
blockages that clog not only your own
drain but entire sewage systems causing
flooding and pollution many places have
laws for proper disposal of grease but
we can go one step further instead of
just throwing it away safely we can turn
it into something useful and if you're
wondering what anyone could possibly
want with a bunch of disgusting used
cooking oil
the answer is biodiesel you've probably
heard of diesel engines they power
farming and construction equipment
trucks buses ships trains backup
generators and even some cars most of
the fuel that feeds these engines is
refined from petroleum which comes from
long dead dinosaurs and other ancient
fossils but diesel fuel can also be
derived from more recently dead
organisms like plants and animals and
this type of fuel is what we call
biodiesel biodiesel is a biodegradable
energy source made from plant oils or
animal fats that can usually be burned
in regular diesel engines you guessed it
it's the bio version of diesel it's
cleaner than normal diesel so there has
been a push to generate it from crops
like soybeans now growing plants for
fuel instead of food comes with its own
problems but fortunately we already have
some oils and fats right here preparing
your used cooking grease for recycling
is easy first let it cool down to room
temperature then transfer it to a clean
container you can use any old bottles
you have lying around like milk jugs as
long as they're completely empty rinsed
and dried use a funnel to avoid spills
and a sieve to filter out any small food
particles you can even add bacon grease
and other animal fats or the excess oil
from canned food like tuna or sardines
just make sure it's really oily and not
brine so what happens now that your oil
is safely contained
well many cities have recycling services
that will pick up large amounts of
grease from restaurant
and other establishments but there are
locations where individuals can drop off
their containers as well all of this
grease will end up at a processing plant
where it can be converted to usable
biodiesel how does this conversion work
well all these oils and fats you donated
are made up of triglycerides a glycerol
molecule connected to three fatty acid
chains to convert fats to fuel they
react with an alcohol usually methanol
or ethanol which produces long-chain
esters and glycerol to compare here are
some molecules of regular diesel fuel
now here are the molecules we created by
breaking apart the triglycerides
glycerol is the odd man out
so it's removed at the end of the
process but look at these esters if you
squint their structures look pretty
similar to those of the long-chain
hydrocarbons in regular diesel and
diesel engines with a few small
modifications can also be made to squint
and burn these esters like regular
diesel fuel
voila biodiesel now you might be
wondering whether all this hassle of
recycling used cooking oil is even worth
it after all how much energy can it
possibly generate well if all the grease
that New Yorkers throw away in one day
were converted to jet fuel it would be
enough to power several hundred flights
from New York to Los Angeles and let's
not forget that using waste oil instead
of burning more fossil fuels will limit
our negative effects on the environment
recycling used cooking grease turns goop
into good by contributing a little bit
individuals and businesses can help
create an alternative stable source of
ezel while protecting the environment
and keeping our cities cleaner and
that's pretty slick
[Music]
you